توجه الى رام الله ومدير المكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري و هنالك ايضا تصريحات ليف
جالنت لكن سبقها تصريحات ايضا عن تغيير في
حكومه نتنياهو يطالب
بها رئيس الوزراء السابق ايهود
براك هود براك يرى ان نتنياهو يتحمل
المسؤوليه كامله ولم يعد اهلا لمواصله
رئاسه الوزراء لذلك هو في حديث للقناه
الثانيه ع قال بانه يجب ايجاد الاليه
لاستبدال بنيامين نتنياهو وايضا ايتمار بن
كبير وزير الامن القومي باخرين لانهم غير
صالحين للاستمرار براك هذا موقفه ليس من
اليوم وانما طيله هذه الحرب وهناك اصوات
كثيره تتعالى بهذا الاتجاه نتنياهو من
ناحيته وكما قال براك يشغل ماكينه تبث
السموم على حد تعبيره اخرها ما كان قد
شارك نجله يئير به من خلال تغري ده على
موقع اكس تويتر سابقا تقول تحاول ان تدفع
بنظريه المؤامره وكان رئيس هيئه الاركان
العسكريه هيرتس هاليفي كان ضمن مؤامره
للاطاحه بوالده في السابع من اكتوبر
الماضي لانه لم يبلغ رئيس الوزراء بامر
هذا الهجوم مسبقا على حد تعبيره هذا كله
يجتمع ليدلل على حاله عدم الثقه المتزايده
في الشارع الاسرائيلي تجاه نتنياهو وتجاه
حكومته اليمينيه المتطرفه والتي يرى
كثيرون بانها بالفعل لم تعد صالحه ويجب
بعد الانتخ بعد الحرب مباشره ان يعتزل
فورا وهناك اخرون يرون ان اعتزاله يجب ان
يكون خلال هذه الحرب لكن نتنياهو كما
نتنياهو يواصل تصريحاته العاليه التي من
خلالها يقول بانه ماض في الحرب ولا شيء
سيوقف وهو الوحيد القادر على منع اقامه ما
يصفها بحم ستان وفتح ستان في قطاع غزه
واقامه نظام امني يخدم المصالح
الاسرائيليه هذه التصريحات التي ادلى بها
نتنياهو امس ورددها جوقه من مؤيديه اليوم
هدفها بالاساس محاوله تثبيت قاعدته
الانتخابيه الائتلافيه ليواصل حكمه بعد
الحرب وايضا محاوله للتاثير على المفاوضات
والاتصالات الجاريه خصوص ابرام صفقه تبادل
جديده للاسرى والتاثير عليها علما ان
المعلومات التي وردت نهار هذا اليوم تشير
الى ان هذه المباحثات قد وصلت الى طريق
مسدود التصريحات الاخرى هي ما وردت على
لسان وزير الدفاع جلنت قبل قليل هذه
التصريحات هي اخرى تحاول ان تشير الى ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي ماض في عملياته وقد اوشك
على تحقيق اهدافه في شمال قطاع غزه وانه
سيعمق من عملياته في خان يونس وجنوب قطاع
غزه ومناطق اخرى حسب تعبيره لكن هذا لا
يتسق تماما مع حقيقه الموقف على الارض
صحيح الجيش دفع باربعه كتائب جديده بعد ان
سحب كتيبه من لواء جولاني هي الكتيبه 13
التي منيت بخسائر فادحه بالارواح بينها
مقتل قائدها حتى وهي التي دخلت في العمليه
البريه منذ بدايتها في ال 26 من اكتوبر
الماضي لكنها منيت بخسائر فاتحه وتحديدا
في حي الشجاعيه حسب الاسرائيليين فان
قواتهم في شمالي القطاع تحقق تقدما واوشكت
على السيطره الكامله لكن في منطقه خان
يونس المعارك ضاريه جدا وهذا اليوم كان قد
اعلن عن قتل مقتل ضابط وجندي واصابه ثلاثه
اخرين بجراح خطيره في معارك في شمال وجنوب
قطاع غزه واللافت هو شمال قطاع غزه الذي
تتواصل فيه القتال رغم ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول انه اجتاحه وانه سوى
العديد من المباني في احياء الشجاعيه
والشيخ رضوان وايضا خان يونس بالارض من
خلال قصفها بقنابل غير مسبوقه كان قبل
اكثر من شهر قد ذكر شهود العيان انهم
كانوا يسمعون دوي هذه القنابل من مسافه 30
كيل مت تقريبا من منطقه اسدود التي تبعد
نحو 30 ك او اكثر عن شمال قطاع غزه لذلك
ما استخدمته استخدم الجيش الاسرائيلي في
قطاع غزه يقدر بنحو 100000 ذخيره بمعنى
قنبله وصاروخ القيت على قطاع غزه وهي ما
تساوي حسب المعلومات سبع اضعاف ما القي
على المانيا النازيه في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه والمانيا النازيه مساحتها 1000
ضعف مساحه قطاع غزه هذا يشير الى ضراوه
هذهه الحرب الداميه والى القتل الذي
تواصله القوات الاسرائيليه فيها والتي
تواصله خلال الايام المقبله اذا صحت صحت
المعلومات بان الامريكيين حددوا لاسرائيل
عمليتها البريه حتى نهايه الاسبوع الاول
من الشهر المقبل